[Aplausos]
cuántos de ustedes creen
[Música]
a través cuántos de ustedes creen que
pueden jugar un juego más grande en su
vida es decir ser mejores quiero ver
excelente gracias
cuántos no cuantos no creen que pueden
jugar un juego más grande en su vida
gracias te lo pregunto por lo siguiente
el creer que puedes o el creer que no
puedes lograr lo que te propones en tu
vida va a ser determinante y sobre todo
cuando la vida te ponga un reto enfrente
cuando la vida te ponga una adversidad
enfrente cuando la vida te muestre
circunstancias que tú no puedes
controlar
definitivamente en si la vida es un reto
considero que la vida en sí ya es un
reto
sin embargo esos retos esas adversidades
esas circunstancias que no controlas
si lo sabemos aprovechar
si sabemos aprender de esas experiencias
en definitiva son los elementos que nos
ayudan a crecer cuanto están de acuerdo
conmigo en eso nos ayudan a crecer nos
ayudan a sacar la mejor versión de
nosotros mismos es más son los elementos
que nos llevan al siguiente nivel
la sicóloga carol dweck en su libro
mindset mentalidad afirma dos cosas de
las creencias que para mí son
fundamentales número uno las creencias
pueden ser conscientes o inconscientes
es decir puedes o no darte cuenta de tus
propias creencias
y las creencias influyen influyen en lo
que tú deseas e inclusive determinan en
gran parte si lo consigues o no
en ese mismo libro the main set ella
determina que existen dos tipos de
mentalidad basados en tus creencias la
mentalidad fija y la mentalidad de
crecimiento que es una mentalidad fija
es aquella mentalidad la cual cree y
aquí volvemos a la palabra clave cree
que nuestras cualidades humanas
son inamovibles es decir están talladas
en piedra
mientras que la mentalidad de
crecimiento es la mentalidad que cree
que tanto las cualidades humanas como
las condiciones las habilidades
intelectuales se cultivan con el
esfuerzo
ella afirma que una simple creencia
es capaz de transformar tu propia
psicología es decir la forma en la que
piensas y por consecuencia tu vida
entera
velo desde esta perspectiva me
encantaría que lo vieras desde esta
perspectiva cuántos de ustedes conocen a
alguna persona que se ha planteado
alguna vez una meta en su vida y no la
ha conseguido alguien conoce alguien lo
puede ser tú mismo
y si me dices que no me voy a preocupar
porque el chiste es que hay que
intentarlo
que es lo que normalmente escuchamos de
una persona que no cumple una meta
normalmente tú mismo te puede estar
escuchando no tuve el tiempo
no tuve o no conseguí el dinero los
recursos
puedes también decir no era lo mío
no no tenía yo los contactos adecuados
en fin yo no digo que no sean razones
válidas no voy a juzgar eso yo no digo
que no sean razones válidas sin embargo
en su libro pensar en grande su libro
perdón
anthony robbins poder sin límites no se
afirma no nos concluye a través de
muchos estudios que no son la falta de
recursos lo que impide que tú logres tus
metas
sino la falta de intención y voluntad
pero también desde esta otra perspectiva
además de tus propios conocimientos y de
tus propias habilidades
el creer en ti mismo el creer que puedes
en ti mismo en ti misma el creer que
puedes lograr algo es lo que detona la
confianza en ti misma o en ti mismo el
elemento fundamental para el logro de
los resultados quién está de acuerdo
conmigo en eso confía en ti
yo no conozco y esta profesión me ha
dado extraordinarias oportunidades yo no
conozco a un solo emprendedor que diga
voy a empezar un proyecto no sé si
funcione pero voy a intentarlo
todo emprendedor cree que su proyecto va
a funcionar independientemente si
funciona o no
de igual manera david watts o david
suárez en su libro pensar en grande la
magia del éxito te dice regla número uno
para lograr tener éxito
creer que puedes tenerlo
y ahí es donde me entran a mí muchas
preguntas de qué depende aumentar esa
confianza en ti cómo puedo yo aumentar
esa confianza en mí mismo en mí misma
creer más en mí
decía yo que aparte de tu conocimiento y
aparte de tus propias habilidades
desarrolladas
es fundamental hacerte plenamente
consciente de la historia que te cuentas
cuando surgen las adversidades la
historia que te cuentas a ti mismo oa ti
misma al momento que surge una
adversidad eso es imprescindible
mira ahorita empezamos la conferencia y
yo te hice la pregunta cuántos de
ustedes creen y de saber si ya está
cuántos de ustedes creen que pueden
jugar un juego más grande en su vida y
sé yo la pregunta correcto me encanta
normalmente no voy a generalizar porque
es muy arriesgado pero normalmente el
100% de la gente levanta la mano y mira
no importa el auditorio no importa son
chavos con ustedes emprendiendo
aprendiendo si son gente de la tercera
edad de tenido la fortuna de trabajar
con todo tipo de personas más de 25 mil
en 15 años
porque todo el mundo levanta la mano
sabes por qué porque el ser humano esa
es mi creencia el ser humano por
naturaleza aspira a tener más
progreso es igual la felicidad necesito
sentir que avanzo bueno al menos yo
y seguramente tú también porque lo he
podido platicar con muchísima gente y
mira no hablo de tener solo más dinero
eso es uno de los elementos que se vale
el tener el ser humano por naturaleza
aspira a tener más
repito no solo cuestiones materiales
puede ser hay gente todos tenemos sueños
aquí quien está de acuerdo conmigo en
eso todos tenemos sueños y metas que
queremos alcanzar hay gente que desea
tener una familia
hay gente que desea tener una carrera
universitaria
hay gente que desea tener su propio
negocio o un mejor lugar para vivir o un
mejor medio de transporte no sé cuál sea
tu sueño pero yo te garantizo que todos
tenemos al menos uno
ahora esta experiencia de más de 25 años
esta experiencia perdón ya vamos a decir
que es que estoy yo te puedo decir que
desde la preparatoria desde la
secundaria aprendes hoy en día te cae el
20 de eso
estos años de experiencia con tanta
gente me han enseñado dos cosas yo he
podido trabajar con gente muy exitosa y
eso es una bendición
me ha enseñado dos cosas fundamentales
que quiero transmitir transmitirte a ti
número 1 tú debes de tener absoluta
claridad de lo que quieres lograr en tu
vida
entonces si mi espíritu que explico con
absoluta claridad de qué color de qué
sabor donde está cómo se siente absoluta
claridad es fundamental sino no hay
dirección
es como subirte un taxi que aberración
acabo de decir veras es como si pides un
taxi por la por la aplicación que es lo
primero que te pide la ubicación y
adónde vas cierto o no
el no tener metas o no tener claridad es
como subirte al taxi que te pregunte el
taxista a dónde vamos usted arranque se
no importa claro que importa los primero
elemento clave en cuestión de
aprendizaje es define ten perfecta
claridad de lo que quieres lograr y
segundo necesitas hacer que las cosas
pasen
es decir necesitas tomar acción mira si
no tomas acción no pasa nada que es lo
único que cae del cielo
el agua correcto hay que trabajar por
ello acuérdate que tomar acción es el
ingrediente indispensable que convierte
tu sueño en realidad la acción es el
ese objetivo esa meta en realidad son
acciones concretas todos los días que te
acerquen a tu sueño por solo tienes que
tener perfectamente claro y esa claridad
y ese motivo son los que te van a ayudar
a sobreponerse a las adversidades
otra pregunta que me surge porque si
todo el mundo tenemos sueños
todo el mundo queremos mejorar queremos
progresar porque aún sabiendo lo que
debemos de hacer muchas veces no lo
hacemos
y ahí viene el tema de hoy existe una
resistencia interna
existe una resistencia a salir de tu
zona de confort
yo le llamo el angelito y el diablito es
muy una opinión muy personal bueno el
héroe y el villano como tú quieras
cuando son es despertador por la mañana
que dice el villano que dice el diablito
cinco minutos más quién está de acuerdo
conmigo en eso cierto no porque si sabes
que tienes que levantarte quieres
levantarte hacer ejercicio empieza el
diablito decir te hace frío
mejor mañana
a cuántos les activo a cuántos conocen a
alguien que le haya pasado eso
el tema es la resistencia interna y
sabes qué es lo que alimenta
constantemente la resistencia interna la
historia que te cuentas cuando las cosas
te suceden la historia de ti mismo a ti
mismo
yo aquí quiero compartir te un pequeño
fragmento de mi vida donde yo me di
perfectamente cuenta de la importancia
de hacerme consciente de la historia que
me cuento cada vez que se presenta una
adversidad o un éxito también porque
también te puedes caer también te puedes
tropezar y es parte de la historia que
quiero contarte el día de hoy yo desde
mucho siempre tuve muchísima claridad en
lo que quería yo lograr yo quería tener
una gran familia y hoy te puedo decir
que bendito sea dios estoy feliz y
agradecido por estar casado con carla mi
esposa por carla ana paula y jimena mis
tres hijas sé que ese sueño que gracias
a dios y segundo yo siempre quise ser
independiente yo siempre quise libertad
y esto hoy
lo tomo estoy lo deduzco de unas
experiencias en la infancia de ciertas
interpretaciones de escasez e
interpretaciones de falta de
reconocimiento
para no hacerte el cuento largo mi
primer emprendimiento fue a los 16 años
derivado de mi pasión por la música puse
un negocio de luz y sonido a los 16 años
oí djs no
16 años que tenía 16 años negocio que
duró 25 años con tres generaciones con
un éxito no quiero sonar primal pero un
éxito extraordinario tres generaciones
mis hermanos mis primos mis primos
yo estudié la carrera ingeniería e
ingeniero industrial y en el cuarto
semestre empecé a trabajar yo quería
tener mi propio negocio pero sabía que
tenga que empezar a tener cierta
experiencia empecé a trabajar en una
empresa que vendía software
empecé de vendedor en ese momento no se
me olvidará tercer o cuarto semestre
cayó a mis manos el primer libro de
desarrollo personal en mis manos
despertando al gigante interior de
anthony robbins es su alimento todavía
aún más mi deseo de ser libre mi deseo
de ser independiente y ahí empezó mi
pasión por el crecimiento y desarrollo
personal
dos años después de estar trabajando
cuatro compañeros de la empresa más otro
que estaba con nosotros uno de los
ingenieros de más edad mentor en el área
profesional para mí uno de mis mejores
mentores nos decidimos independizar
buscamos una representación y logramos
formar nuestro negocio propio siete años
después logramos la fusión con nuestra
representada fuimos parte de esa empresa
compraron nuestra organización nos
quedamos con acciones y me dieron el
puesto de director comercial
cinco años después me dan el puesto de
la dirección general todo estaba como
miel sobre ojuelas y va de campeonato
pero la vida te tiene preparadas a veces
muchas sorpresas el 11 de febrero no se
me va a olvidar nunca 11 de febrero del
2008 entra por la puerta de mi oficina
donde los más altos ejecutivos de
nuestra representada ahora socia ya
éramos socios michelle louise estamos
muy contentos con su trabajo pero tu
último día en la empresa es hoy
después de 18 años de trabajar con ellos
claro que a veces ideas te lo puedes
tener programado no en ese momento no lo
tenía programado no era consciente sabía
que podría pasar fueron los peores
momentos de experiencia profesional no
sabía qué hacer fueron momentos de
terror la historia que yo me estaba
contando era de terror brincaron mis
fantasmas de escasez de falta de
reconocimiento inseguridad terror pavor
como iba a llegar a decirles que me
corrieron
seis meses terribles hasta que dije
sabes que esto no me va a llevar a
ningún lado recordé mis libros de
superación personal tomé mis libros pedí
ayuda y empecé a cambiar mi informe
enfoque empecé a cambiar mi patrón de
pensamiento y ahí es cuando me di cuenta
que para poder cambiar la historia hay
que trabajar en tus formas de ser en tu
estado del ser porque porque el ser
humano tiene más de 60 mil pensamientos
todos los días y los estudios del doctor
yo dispensa dicen que el 90% son
negativos si te quedas ahí te vas en un
bucle descendente
cambia tu forma de pensar mismos
pensamientos mismas decisiones mismas
conductas mismas experiencias mismas
emociones que alimentan los mismos
pensamientos si son negativos ahí te
encargo
si estás completamente en el malestar la
mayor parte del tiempo es muy peligroso
yo quiero concluir esta charla el día de
hoy con una anécdota
de sant y mora de su libro en alquimia
emocional que dice tú no puedes
controlar tu no puedes elegir tus
circunstancias pero siempre puedes
elegir lo que sientes respecto a ellas y
el cómo respondes a ellas los accidentes
pasan las enfermedades llegan sin duda
las crisis financieras pegan no puedes
hacer nada es inevitable son las
historias que te cuentas de las cosas
que a ti te pasan las que van a
determinar el cómo afrontas cada
experiencia eres la historia que te
cuentas gracias
[Aplausos]